Hey, David, I'm in I'm from Australia and I'm
trying to figure out why so many Americans
do not vote. Isn't it obvious that it is
just the fundamental basic participation
in your democracy and that it is the
starting point for all political involvement?
Yes. Yes. I you know, for me, I have said many
times I don't believe in this stuff of if you
don't vote, you don't get to complain.
That seems kind of silly and reductive.
But I do think that anybody who cares
at all about the country they live in
should, as a minimum be voting in addition
to whatever else they are doing. Now,
the question of why more people don't vote is a
good question. It's easy to say, well, more people
don't vote because it's not mandatory. That's
not what what I think is really the interesting
part. The more interesting part to me is what
are the reasons that people choose not to vote?
And there's a very interesting study of nonvoters,
and you can find this on the 538 website.
And it looked at why voters versus nonvoters
end up not voting, but rather it compared
the reasons that people who never vote don't vote
versus the reasons that people who sometimes vote
don't end up voting. One of the reasons that
nonvoters choose never to vote is they believe
that it doesn't matter who wins. Nothing will
change for people like them and on. Fortunately,
this is one of those kind of fallacious beliefs,
you know, we hear this idea that sometimes people
will say elections really never come down
to one vote. So therefore my vote doesn't
matter. So I'm going to stay home. And while
it's true that elections rarely come down to
one vote, particularly national elections, if
everybody who had that thought occur to them
stayed home or voted, then you actually would be
able to change the outcomes and maybe influence
what your day to day life is like. So that's
a really unfortunate one. One of the reasons
it feels like things don't change is so many
people aren't voting. If everybody was voting,
things would actually change. Another reason that
nonvoters often don't vote is they believe the
system is too broken to be fixed by voting. That's
sort of a version of the same thing. And then
some folks who believe that because of where they
live, their vote doesn't matter, which is a direct
critique of the Electoral College. And then
lastly, one of the reasons that a lot of
nonvoters cite for not voting is they're not sure
if they can vote, which is really just depressing.
There are situations in which you would not be
allowed to vote because of a criminal conviction.
And we know that that's being dealt with at the
state level in a variety of different states.
But other than not knowing if you are registered
or knowing when you can register, I mean,
the idea that people don't vote because
they're not sure if they can vote,
that's a failure of the system for sure. And then
you have to look at which party has an interest in
reducing voter turnout. And of course, we
know that it's been the Republican Party.
We know that the Republican Party has covertly
been working on reducing turnout for decades and
overtly doing it for at least 10 or 12 years.
Check out the Mike Turzai video back in 2012,
I believe it is, where he openly says voter ID
is going to deliver Pennsylvania to Mitt Romney.
So that's just a depressing reality. Now, we could
solve a lot of these problems if we eliminate this
idea of voter registration, if it's simply you
turn 18 and you're a citizen, you can vote. You
don't need to register. That resolves a lot of
the issue as to whether one is allowed to vote.
That should be done. If we deal with this issue
of have I been purged or do I need ID or not,
all of these things that when we talk about voter,
there's a reason it's called voter suppression.
It really does suppress the vote. And then, of
course, people feeling like the system is broken.
I mean, to some degree I sympathize with them.
And at the same time, I recognize that the lower
participation is in elections. The more broken
it's going to be, the more the system will be
representative of those who choose to vote.
So the voting voting is just the starting
point. I get that voting isn't everything,
but it is depressing when I see, you know,
fifty two percent turnout. Fortunately, we were
over 60 percent this November. But this is a
real problem in the United States. I don't
know that you really solve it in a deep way
simply by making voting mandatory. My birth
country of Argentina has mandatory voting.
I don't know that it in itself gives us
less corrupt outcomes, but that's a bigger
issue and probably one for a different day.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access by becoming
a member at join Pakman Dotcom.